oh gary washburn what's up you in the
bubble going on man
what's up fellas what's going on man
i'm all right two ten weeks in so uh
got about a month left we'll see what
happens man let's see if i make it
did you have to break up a fight last
night no i had to break up a fight
um i heard you know things i heard a lot
of commotion
and i've seen enough arguments to know
that when it's one person jumping on a
lot of people
or a lot of people going at a lot of
people and last night there was a lot of
people going at a lot of other people
so uh the whole market smart was going
at everybody
not true it was a lot of yelling in that
room
it was uh a long long argument
a long sports argument uh you know
we've all been outside of locker rooms
and heard some commotions but this was
about 20 minutes and it was uh it was
heated
team is imploding gary washburn
that's what she said last night now
since your tweet i believe they had what
i like a meeting among
leadership you still based on that
recording based on your knowledge of
this team
oh i'm sorry you still feel that way
that they're imploding i feel like
last night the fourth quarter they kind
of gave in they let go of the rope again
and then frustrations boiled over so
they're frustrated they're a frustrated
team they don't know how to beat this
team
the miami heat they don't know how to
close out games
they let jimmy butler become jimmy
buckets and
jimmy superstar in the last five minutes
of games three steals in the last five
minutes
they still don't know it seems that
goran dragic is left-handed
so he goes left
to the left to his left so he can maybe
go right
instead of letting him go left every
time it's just things that
they said they won three of the four
quarters last night they lost the third
quarter by 20.
that was the difference they are playing
out playing miami first
most of the game but when it counts
they're getting
they're getting beat down uh
gary one of the brothers from another
thinks that the series is over
began the show that way uh i think that
brother said
nah it's a wrap if i'm quoting correctly
and then another brother you know
probably you know slightly uh slightly
older
slightly more intelligent right
it's zip two it's zip two we've seen
teams come back from zip two deficits
what say you what's going on with the
series we got five games left
potentially what do you think
i don't think it's just dead and gone
over but it doesn't look good for the
celtics and they got to figure out
something over the next
24 30 hours or whatever to figure out
how to beat this team and to play
together
and to play hard for 48 minutes i think
one game will help turn the tide the
momentum
because guys they get three days off
after game three they don't play till
wednesday
that's three days to practice take a
deep breath feel good about yourself
feel good about what you did in the
previous game and remember guys
toronto was about to go down 0-3 hit a
game-winning shot and suddenly turned
into a real competitive series that went
seven games
okc was down 0-2 won the next two turn
into a seven game series so
there's hope but in a a lot of hope
yeah hey you know what just even this
conversation
and just the general conversation around
this series i like to kind of reframe it
if i could gee
because it's like you go back to the
last series what was the story it's
about the heat bucks
sorry that story was the bucks losing
not the heat winning it was giannis and
mike budenholzer it was him falling off
sure
coming up short falling short this
series right now
it would say celtics trailing heat
o2 versus heat winning the series
to oh and i guess i just like to try to
focus on miami
and like focus on what miami is doing as
opposed to what the celtics
are not doing so what are you seeing
from this heat team that's only lost
once once in this postseason
and that and everything it's clicking on
all cylinders it can't just be other
teams
not handling their business what are the
heat particularly good at that's
flummoxing
with teams like the celtics and before
them the bucks and before them the
pacers
they're playing a very connected way i
mean they just
all seem on the same page we all have
covered sports for a long time and you
can see
teams that just one they really like
each other okay everyone has a role
there's no bickering about
minutes and two they're connected
they're connected defensively
they all trust each other they trust
from tyler hero the rookie to duncan
robinson the guy undrafted who played
division three then transferred to
michigan
to jimmy buckets obviously to bam out of
bio who's emerging as a superstar
like they all have this trust for each
other and remember guys they
added andre iguodala and jay crowder
mid-season those are two tough guys
those two guys
that are culture guys that they don't
they don't play that stuff with with not
giving 100 percent so you give jimmy two
more guys including the guy he played
with that marquette
and jimmy and jay had their differences
in the past in the nba or whatever they
cool now
and that's a bad thing for the rest of
the league that they didn't come
together
and brought these superpowers together
so you bring that with iguodala
it's a great shooting in terms of
robinson and hero
then also gordon dragic the wily 34 year
old
point guard who's not always been
healthy but when he's played he's played
well but you don't really know about him
common basketball fans probably wouldn't
know who he was but he's just so
effective
so they're all playing on one string
they're all playing
together spoelstra obviously one of the
better coaches the one of the top five
coaches in the league
so yeah you need to talk about miami now
could they beat the lakers
in the next round or potentially i think
they could be the nuggets but the lakers
we don't know about that but in this
series they've been
the better team thanks for that
hallelujah gary because i want to talk
about the lakers
next before you came on i told michael
smith look
lebron james giving you 10 assists a
game and 25 points alongside anthony
davis
i just don't see it i don't see the
nuggets taking it from
the lakers how about you you think this
could be a real series
i think they can win one or two games i
think game one
is with any series is critical for the
team that's the underdog
uh the lakers have had a long layoff the
nuggets coming off that great comeback
against the clippers maybe they can
catch them
sleeping remember they look lakers lost
game one to houston and lost game one to
portland
so denver making a statement playing
hard not like
not giving up not letting go of the rope
not getting discouraged
like they didn't get obviously against
the clippers when they fell behind
18 20 points if they fall behind early
just keep playing through the game
take it to the second half and then rely
on your superstars rely on murray ryan
yokic
even guys like paul millsap and gary
harris let me rely
on what got you there but just hang
close i think lebron and those guys are
going to want to make a statement
and remember guys we're talking about
lebron now they got kind of skunked for
the mvp
i thought it would be a much closer vote
i voted for lebron
and did you yes i did
lebron expound on that uh i just thought
what he did for the lakers leading the
league and assist
i like giannis i like giannis a lot and
jonas put up the big numbers i just
thought what lebron did for that team at
age 35
he deserved my mvp vote i mean i just
thought
bringing bringing them back after having
a terrible
first year in la just what he was able
to do all around
incorporating his teammates bringing
guys like avery bradley
rajon rondo jarrett dudley guys who have
been either cast offs or
you know guys who have been to a bunch
of other teams and bringing them
together and having that cohesive unit
and having the best record in the west i
thought he deserved
so i'm sorry i got you on track i think
you're about to say that he could have a
little bit more fuel
to his fire because it was like 85 16.
lebron yeah where david motivated lebron
now
who saw you know giannis get to get the
award you know in his house in his
living room
and lebron's still here in the bubble so
he's going to be motivated to prove that
he is still the best player in the
league i think we all have seen that
and after what happened with the
clippers i don't know if we can have the
kauai argument right now
so uh if denver can withstand that
and try to hang in there and maybe steal
one of the first two games
i believe they can make it a series if
not i got lakers in five
i'd love to focus real quick michael
holland michael holly i like the focus
real quick though
on the match up in the middle well
actually i don't know if you could tell
in the middle because it's so versatile
uh you know down the perimeter just as
much but like jokish versus davis
is just i think that's where the series
gets decided is which of those
bigs performs uh better we know what
lebron's gonna bring
uh you know jamalmer is gonna get his
but honestly you know talk about stars
winning this series
i think it starts right there with those
two guys how do you see that matchup
playing out g
i mean it's funny because they they're
kind of in a sense alike because they
both like to play away from the basket
i mean dave is obviously a better off uh
defensive player but joking
me he's so crafty i i i'm very
fascinated to see
what he when he brings davis away from
the basketball kind of moves he
he uses how he tries to maybe get
david's in some foul trouble
um because joking has so many so many
moves left right
you know he can he can shoot without
jumping all those of those
that he has i mean he's like the oldest
25 year old in the history of the nba
and he's the guy who's
going to be like all ymca over 50
until he's about 75 so joking i think is
just
a crafty guy i'm fascinated by that
matchup
and will davis want to bring him in the
paint or will davis
rely on the perimeter sometimes davis
gets accused of playing too much away
from the basket it will be interesting
to see how that goes and also where the
lakers play their two other big guys
uh howard and javale mcgee and whether
you know like how plumley fits into that
i mean what how all that
uh kind of matches up and who guards
lebron i'm
kind of fascinated to see who's gonna is
it milsap that's a tough matchup
for milsap um but yeah the yogic david
davis matchup is fascinating all right
final question for you gary washburn
what's your favorite thing about the
bubble
uh the basketball just uh being able to
walk from one game to another
being able to go from one playoff game
you walk down the hill
and you're at the arena for another one
i mean you're never going to see that
again
um there's a lot of other things that we
could talk about maybe on another show
about life here but that is the the best
part is the being able
it's it's like a basketball convention
um you can just this is a show man this
is a show you talk about the other stuff
we talk about
hey man come on we take the we have we
say this over and over we ripped the
curtain down on brother from another cup
what you what you what you holding back
on like what else
all right well okay you guys saw the
movie life right
of course yeah absolutely so
they got angle call it the gun line but
they got a line you can't cross
and there's a loop that everybody jogs
runs around and they got signs like you
just like this
that's just funny to me you know you
just if you cross this line
the same air exists but if you cross
this line
you get put back into the door same air
the same air everything is a normal
it's the street it's cars and all that
and if you just
if you just like martin if you run for
that cherry pie
because you've been smelling that cherry
pie for 20 years and you just
want to see the street no uh
quarantine um i am so glad you invoked
life
because for my money eddie murphy's best
film best movie yeah
love it and uh thank you for you gotta
we got in
and you can ask anybody else down here
about the peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches
they're they're like cigarettes i mean
oh
they used to be then they stopped making
them they started making them kind of
bad we're like ninety percent peanut
butter
they're using smooth or crunchy uh
smooth
smooth but a lot of spoons
because the dinner hours are so limited
that if you literally are covering a
game you just grab three or four
if you have some pb and j's in your room
at midnight you were just like
you know you were like doing that you're
your partner
i mean it's it's like that because
if this is the snack emporium like i
have had so many barbecue that i try to
stay away from that
you know we get no younger but here i
mean
all the the only food they have
available if you miss
breakfast lunch or dinner or these
snacks
so you're relegated to eating eating
stuff that you
haven't eaten in years i have not had so
many peanut butter and jelly sandwiches
i was 13 years old i mean
it's it's insane um so yeah there's a
little there's a lot we could go into
uh some of it's some of it's good some
of it's not so good but
the basketball has been amazing seeing
everybody around
getting to know guys as i said you walk
this loop you'll see nba head coaches
getting their walk on officials
you know assistant coaches etc so it's a
real kind of we're all in the same
journey so you got give each other that
head nod
and uh the testing you know you do
i got these two things here the uh
temperature and then your oxygen
saturation you take
you do that every morning and if you
don't they send you a text message about
noon like
hey man you need to do that and you
can't get into any venue
without doing that so if you're we hit
this uh band here we don't take it off
with the mickey logo i don't know if you
can see it the mickey kind of
uh logo on it but we ain't getting to
know rides we can't have fun with this
this gets us into any venue arena and if
that thing turns blue
you got to go back to your room and do
the testing again
um so the nba is not playing with this
kobe they don't
mess around reporters anybody
you have to test every day you have to
take oxygen every day
and put it in the app so it is like a
routine and you just have to get used to
it
really interesting gary washburn man we
appreciate you eight man keep out of
those spikes
make sure don't be hanging around
let
good to see you brother